car ilham la cheffe de l'exécuter par
kong est réputé pour être libre à la bhl
a fléchi
elle se dit profondément désolé pour
toute la controverse suscitée par sa
volonté d'autoriser les extraditions
vers la chine continentale
elle continue de défendre la nécessité
du projet mais décide de le suspendre
indéfiniment pour rétablir le calme et
l'ordre à soon as possible pour éviter
qu'il y ait d'autres blessés enjoy
[Applaudissements]
il semble que les violences de mercredi
dernier était un tournant la goutte de
trop même pour certains élus pro pékin
qui font face à l'électorat hong kong et
dans les prochains mois
kerry l'âme était de plus en plus isolé
des observateurs croient que le
président chinois xi jinping a préféré
limiter les dégâts pour se concentrer
sur d'autres batailles plus pressante
comme la guerre commerciale avec les
états unis d'où l'aval de pékin à la
suspension sera recul bienvenue par les
uns heureux que les signaux d'alarmé et
été entendus mais pour les autres ce
n'est pas assez les opposants veulent le
retrait comme tel de ce projet de loi
qui comporte à leurs yeux plein de
menaces malgré les assurances réitérées
par la chef de l'exécutif à savoir par
exemple que les droits seraient protégés
étant athé ils promettent de ne rien
lâcher
son insert et surtout qu'ils craignent
une ruse de queyries l'âme
l'ampleur de la mobilisation dimanche
dira si elle a su calmer le jeu ou non
hygiéniques béraud radio canada hong
kong